yeah this is insane this is no one can
create a viral video and anyone that
says to you that can make a viral video
it's gonna be liners like you cannot
reverse engineer a viral video 72 hours
of video uploaded to YouTube every
minute less than three percent of videos
upload to you to go over 1,000 views hi
my name is David wha and I'm an
entertainer living in Los Angeles I've
been given seven chances to create a
viral video this is my adventure and I
invite you to come home with me can I go
viral can we tell you what I all I do
like Tara okay go there we go that was
awesome she's so naughty she's so
naughty yeah yeah oh the heart the
hardest thing about black ghosts they
just don't want to leave so that's the
thing so you know I'm reading some
poltergeist so some haunted house
mansion the day Satan call just a lot of
Geno just trying to make sure get these
black ghosts out cuz black goes all of
you watch like Maury and stuff like that
would it be like you know like i am
leaving I'm not leaving don't tell me to
leave I'm not moving so it's like it's
hard to you know what the black goes to
try to like because I don't know why
they never do movies on black ghosts
because obviously the movies gums is
gonna be an extended movie cuz black
goes just don't they don't want to leave
so everybody's dealing with some issues
that people got roaches and stuff if I
got black goes it's crazy they come
through they knock and they sing an old
Negro spirituals it's crazy I don't know
exactly um yeah this insane this is I
think I try to get rid of them in
January and they're still around that's
the thing so I'm talking to like a
priest and stuff to try to get these
black doses out and now I'm just like
you know what you know what I miss
not like it's like a raid go spray that
you can actually spray doses and then
have them disappear so you just got to
get like people with like you know like
just ministers or just like people who
handle exorcism and [ __ ] stuff like that
so yeah that's kind of crazy sighs one
up yeah it's the stuff I'm reading right
now I'm almost through with it though
it's the library so I'm just gonna bring
it back actually some of them books are
overdue but don't tell anybody it's
giving you guys a heads up on that yeah
shelled out the whole just out that's it
I am an alcoholic I didn't even realize
it in my fridge was just nothing but
alcohol I can't do that it's like not
this note there's no meets nothing in
there look at that refrigerator she's
just all beer alcohol water when I get
dehydrated if I'm trying to like you
know but that's it no meats no foods
nothing like that that's just crazy all
alcohol products people this is it right
here up into the top every alcohol you
need right here every every chaser that
you could possibly leave so the girl
would never leave you like you know what
you don't have aren't just like I got it
you don't have redbull I got it you
don't have sugar free I got it you don't
have Diet Coke I got it you don't got
regular coke I got it whatever you need
red wine I got white wine I got
champagne you know I got mark Rita
margarita mix I got everything you
cannot be like well you have that
special holiday I got the four seasons
boys to men I mean you cannot there's
nowhere you can leave this place I click
on my goody snacks check out my goody
snacks right here by goody snacks I got
oatmeal cookie half will oatmeal cookie
I got chocolate decadence I got that I
got peanut butter if you got peanut
butter allergy we got regular regular
eminem's non peanuts you know it just
it's just so much going on here Jack
Daniels vodka ciroc coconut vodka flo
rida loves this stuff um we got
everything in here margarita mix like I
tell you this is but there's no food in
it I guess that's why I'm so skin
because there's no there's no actual
meat there's no there's no food in here
but just alcohol
that's it join me David war for the next
episode of can I go viral well I was
soon attempt to make a viral YouTube
video